[Music]
now
to cuba where protests across the island
are posing a serious challenge to the
socialist leadership
why the protest now how is the regime
reacted
and will supporters of socialism around
the world finally criticize the cuban
government
i'm joined by chris sabatini a senior
fellow at chatham house who specializes
in the politics of latin america
chris thanks for joining us on spectator
tv to start are these protests just a
reaction to the consequences of the
pandemic or something bigger happening
these are long-standing demands and
grievances the cuban people have had i
mean obviously the pandemic has worsened
them
first of all because of the lack of
access to medicine and the collapsed
health care system cuba is often
celebrated
for its revolution in health care but
the truth is it's fallen apart
long ago it's deeply romanticized and
now pretty much a myth and so
what you're seeing is people's reaction
to that but also the economy has
crumbled in 2020
the economy contracted by 11 and that's
largely uh because of the restrictions
on kovid
that led to uh the tourism uh declining
dropping off almost entirely not just
from the united states because of the
embargo but from
the europe from europe from latin
america from canada
but also the economy itself is just it's
just creaking along it's a
tired old communist system that's
failing to produce enough food for the
people has to import most of its food
and as the economy and the country try
to unify
its very complicated dual exchange rate
just last year
that led to a spike in the prices of
imported food
so people were experiencing both
shortages and high prices in most of the
dollar or foreign currency exchange
stores so between health care
between lack of access to food out right
hunger to be perfectly honest in
malnutrition
and just desperation that's what we're
seeing expressed now but obviously covid
was probably the tipping point at least
in terms of
the health care concerns of and the
government is of course blaming the
united states but the protesters simply
aren't buying it
yeah of course they're blaming the
united states and they would uh you know
they can't admit their own failures and
so they
go to the traditional straw man of
blaming the u.s embargo and the embargo
may be a clumsy
policy tool personally i think that's
the case but uh it's not the reason
whether
why there are shortages or why the
economy has failed or or even
why the health care system is falling
apart uh but and they're also believing
the united states
alleging that it supported the
protesters but you need only look at the
number of
cities in which people have taken to the
streets across
cuba uh and realized that this is can't
be orchestrated from anyone or anywhere
but also
the nature of the protests themselves
these people aren't demanding
necessarily regime change although
that's an element of it given the
brittleness of the regime and its lack
of accountability
they're really demanding just basic
goods uh you know bread and butter
issues
um and that's really what's driving this
and for that reason this is really cuts
to the quick
for the cuban government i mean it's
failed to provide for its people this is
a revolution that sort of sustained
itself
largely on the myth but sustained itself
on the idea that it's a revolution that
provides for the poor
uh and it simply can't uh tolerate the
idea that suddenly those people are
taking the streets and denouncing the
government and their own
and announcing to the world their own uh
basic needs
one interesting thing by the way about
the the protest if you look at the
videos
what you see is these are not you know
the traditional human rights activists
and dissidents
uh that have often been you know if you
will sort of
part of u.s discussion and dialogue on
these issues
largely these are afro-descendant cubans
people who who would have
uh decades ago claim to have benefited
from the revolution are now taking the
streets
so this really goes to the very heart of
the revolution in its own
failings so in his piece for
the spectator this week rory says this
sort of thing just doesn't happen
in cuba and you're hinting at that as
well that something feels really
different this time compared to how it's
been in the past
yeah i would say there are a couple of
things that are different uh within the
island kate
uh the first is that we see again
the socio-economic differences of this
of this uh just in terms of the people
on the streets their racial composition
their age uh multi-sectoral as i
mentioned it's artists it's artisans
it's it's
uh small entrepreneurs the second thing
that's different about this
is their coordination by social media
and and this is
unheard of you're seeing uh for the
first time
people plan and and organize facebook
events
um share videos of crackdowns but also
protesters
um which is added to a certain element
of courage people are sort of saying
we're not afraid that's what they're
saying
and this is very much in the article
that you mentioned the spectator and
that's important
people suddenly they feel empowered
social media is at their fingertips
uh and we've seen of course as you would
expect the cuban government just tried
to shut down the internet
um it can't entirely but it's trying to
nip this in the bud
there's two other things that make this
important another one as i mentioned is
that this is about bread and butter
issues
yes it's about freedom yes it's about
human rights yes it's about denouncing
the regime
but it really is about socioeconomics at
its heart and
that's unique in many ways i think it's
a very powerful message
there's one last thing that's very
important about this is
as media has become more savvy and
international
as the regime has had to tolerate some
pushes by the international community
to open up in some ways marginally we
now have a really good cohort
of international correspondents that are
on the ground
as well as working with independent
journalists from cuba in
cuba on the ground reporting on this so
in this case
what we're seeing is that the the
actions of these people are being
broadcast through social media
through traditional media but also
through local media
independent journalists as i mentioned
like joanie sanchez and others are
posting this and blogging about it and
reporting it in live time
but they're also reporting on the
crackdown that we've seen there are
pictures of bloodied
one person has died a bloodied
photographer from the ap
this is going to be very very powerful
powerful because often in the past
the numbers of journalists that space
has been very limited and consequently
they've been able
basically the regime has been able to
repress with impunity
well you mentioned at the start of this
interview that many of the reasons that
protesters have taken to the streets are
that they are disappointed with what is
quite frankly
a failed uh socialist regime
and as you point out there's a lot of
international attention on
this now because the press from very
local press to the international press
is giving it quite rightly that
attention i've noticed that a lot of
voices who would often be sympathetic to
those ideas
um in the international community in
western countries are
oddly silent on this one do you think
they're going to have to pipe up and
make a comment on it at some point
you know i'm not sure about that again
lenin referred to people like that as
useful idiots for the revolution they're
sort of unwittingly enabled or complied
with uh
revolution and the denial of people's
rights um i think it's gonna be very
difficult for some people to part with
the myth and the romanticization of of
the castros
uh of uh the regime i'd like to believe
that but you know having worked on cuba
for a long time
and having uh experienced and tried to
mobilize
uh people to react to uh crackdowns in
the past for example the
this black spring of 2003 i i've just
been astounded by the double standards
and hypocrisy of
of people who are willing to denounce
human rights abuses say in chile under
pinochet
um and then just suddenly shy away from
doing so in cuba and i
i suspect that me that may be the case i
mean there are a few i think that will
start to speak out michelle bachelet
who's a
high commissioner for human rights at
the u.n has been very shy about speaking
out before on cuba in fact
it's alleged i haven't confirmed this
that she has never personally spoken out
on human rights abuses in cuba i think
it's going to be very difficult for them
to do that but i think other people a
number of academics
journalists and like artists uh are
going to be a little bit reticent to do
that
and it's a shame because whereas in the
past maybe they could try to fool
themselves
maybe when a castro was in power they
could claim that this was
you know this was the mantle of a
revolutionary leader and they're still
beholden to all those myths of the
revolution but now it's it's post castro
and the images are clear not just to the
crackdown but also the people that are
on the streets
but i honestly i hate to sound cynical i
don't have any great faith in people
that before have been silent suddenly
speaking up
yeah and i'm i'm going to be cynical
along there with you
and i'm also going to ask you a very
broad question so forgive me in advance
but i'm just so curious
about how the political attitudes are
shifting in cuba
now you know we want to avoid
stereotypes because like any other
country you're going to have a broad
spectrum
of political opinion but in relation to
these protests i mean
if they were to have some success what
would that success look like and what
are the new political demands that are
growing
in cuba and and is there a divide
between say the younger generations and
the older generations that might be
slightly more sympathetic to the regime
well it's a good question and it's
difficult as you say because
cuba's diverse it's large it's a country
of 11 million people
um i just tell a few anecdotes about
this because i think they're
illustrative
one time i was in cuba i was having
dinner uh with a group of young
uh people not necessarily activists they
were just university of havana students
that like young professionals and i
asked them you know what do you
what do you think um because by way of
context most people in cuba recognize
the failings of the regime they
recognize and they'll speak quietly and
in hush tones
about you know the need for change
but they don't really want to speak out
and i ask these young kids
what do you hope for and almost to a
person they said we hope to leave
we have no future here and that's very
difficult and what's interesting now
is suddenly is that sense of desperation
that lack of of hope
may suddenly be being challenged to the
street rather than an effort to flee
and that's positive and i think once you
build that once you build that sense of
of hope then you get what what your
article says as people start to speak
about
the lack of fear they're not as afraid
uh and i think that's very very
important
in terms of pockets of support for the
regime you know it's very difficult to
tell of course there are people in the
government
who very much support support the regime
but you never know i mean as i
when i used to teach at columbia
university i would tell my students
you know try and describe what it's like
in cuba and the conversations you have
privately with people
you know imagine working in an office
where the same boss has been in power
for 60 years
how frustrating would that be you know
that person just
personally controls everything that
happens in the office and it depends on
on his whim uh would not be a work
environment that you'd want to work in
so we don't even know within the
government how much they support this
and lastly is one other element to this
which is very different
which is there's not a caster on power
right now last year raul castro stepped
down for the presidency of the
communist party before that he stepped
down from the presidency of the country
and this is going to be important
because you know you don't have that
myth of the revolution again you don't
have
the the cadre of guerrillas guerrillas
that were around
fidel well castro empower anymore it's a
new generation and they lack
that legitimacy that sort of
revolutionary cred if you will
um and consequently what you've heard
from diaz canel miguel diaz-canel the
president
is he's going to respond in a
revolutionary manner what he's saying is
i'm no different than the castros i'm
going to respond
the same way with an iron fist and it's
a message not just to the people and
he's called them as revolutionaries to
the streets
it's also a message to those around him
saying i'm not going to give up
don't we we're not we're not going
forward this is the same old regime and
i'm abiding by our
cafe maximo our chief leader the now
deceased fidel castro
chris thanks for coming on the show
[Music]
you